en el vídeo pasado estábamos haciendo
este problema que estaba bien
emocionante y teníamos un alambre lo
cortamos hicimos un triángulo equilátero
y un cuadrado y queríamos ver dónde
cortar para minimizar la suma de las
áreas y el área combinada ya habíamos
encontrado una expresión para esa área
combinada y ahorita lo que vamos a hacer
es justamente optimizarlo ok entonces
vamos a bajar vamos a reescribir esta
área tantito para que sea más fácil
derivar la después entonces nos queda
igual y me lo voy a poner así raíz de
303 través de 3 dividido entre 3 al
cuadrado es 99 por 42 36 nos queda 36 x
x cuadrada más y este de acá no lo voy a
cambiar tanto le voy a poner 100 menos x
al cuadrado dividido entre 4 y perdón
dividido entre 16 que es 4 al cuadrado y
lo de arriba no lo voy a desarrollar
porque es latoso mejor ahorita aplicamos
la regla de la cadena bueno ya con esta
expresión vamos a derivar entonces vamos
a ponerle a prima de x con este color
amarillo pastel la prima de x es igual a
derivando aquí tenemos el 2
con el 36 se hace un entre 18 entonces
nos queda a raíz de 3 dividido entre 18
por x más y aquí el 2
mira que aquí es donde tenemos que esa
regla de la cadena de aquí tenemos algo
elevado al cuadrado entonces la derivada
es lo de afuera derivado que es dos
veces blablabla
evaluado en lo de adentro entonces nos
quedaría 2% menos equis y luego
multiplicado por la derivada de lo de
adentro la derivada de 100 menos x es
menos 1 x menos 1 y hay que dividir
entre el 16 entre 16 muy bien este 2 con
este 16 se hace un 8 sale y entonces que
nos queda nos queda raíz de 3 dividido
entre 18 por x más y aquí como están las
cosas menos 1 por menos x es x entre 8
es x octavos x octavos vale y luego nos
queda este 100 con este 8 con un signo
menos 100 entre 8 50 entre 4 que es 25
entre 2 que es 12.5 no voy a poner como
12.5 muy bien estoy aquí es la expresión
de la derivada fácil para optimizar la
función original tenemos que ver donde
la derivada o bien no está definida o
bien es igual a 0 pero esta derivada
está definida para todas las x es verdad
no hay problema no estamos dividiendo
entre x no podemos dividir entre 0
entonces pues no hay de esos puntos no
hay puntos críticos porque no esté
definida entonces nada más debe haber
puntos críticos porque esto sea igual a
cero
vamos a encontrar los valores de x que
satisfacen eso que nos quedaría en el
12.5 lo pasamos a la izquierda sumando
es decir sumamos 12.5 de ambos lados nos
queda que 12.5 es igual a raíz de 3
entre 18 más
un octavo x x xi aquí nada más a
sociedad y entonces dividiendo entre
esto entre esta expresión medio fea que
es raíces de 3 entre 18 más un octavo
nos queda que x es igual a 12.5 12.5
dividido
dividido entre esto era k raíz de 3
entre 18 más un 8º ching se ve
monstruoso verdad bueno tiene un raíz de
tres y fracciones infracciones en el
denominador entonces es un poquito feo
pero no le hace aquí ya encontramos el
valor de x y pues con esto ya más o
menos la icem o ya más o menos la
hicimos ahora tenemos que ver que en
efecto esto de aquí es un mínimo verdad
porque queremos minimizar las áreas cómo
le hacemos pues ahora pasamos al
criterio de la segunda derivada déjame
poner la segunda derivada aquí a la
derecha en color hueso entonces tenemos
a doble prima de x
a doble prima de x pues cuál nos
conviene derivar esta está fea vamos a
derivar esta que es la es la misma
expresión verdad entonces nos queda a
raíz de 3 entre 18 y 18 más la derivada
de x octavos o sea más un octavo y la
derivada de esto que es 0 esto de aquí
en la segunda derivada observa que son
dos constantes mayores iguales que 0 al
sumarlo nos queda mayor o igual que 0
bueno de hecho mayor estricto eso lo que
nos dice es que las funciones cóncava
hacia arriba cóncava hacia arriba hacia
arriba
o sea haciendo el dibujito nos queda
como una 1 igual y como nos queda como
una u la pendiente primero empieza así
muy negativa luego va subiendo va
subiendo aquí en este punto se hace 0
sube y sube y sube pero como tiene forma
de v entonces este punto donde la
pendiente 0 tiene que ser un mínimo
entonces este aquí es un mínimo mínimo
muy bien entonces bueno ya logramos
descubrir que esto de aquí es un mínimo
o sea este este punto va a servir para
encontrar el valor mínimo pero digo o
sea tenemos que hacer un corte al final
de cuentas entonces si si le damos este
valor a alguien para que corte el
alambre seguro se va a enojar entonces
ya nada más como última cosa para que no
nos quede una expresión tan fea vamos a
meter es para la calculadora para ver
cuánto nos da vale entonces la voy a
aprender borro
y tenemos que hacer 12.5 12.5 dividido
entre y entre paréntesis va raíz de tres
entre 18
a raíz de 3 entre 18 vale más más uno
8º
ok déjame ver que todo esté bien 12.5 /
raíz de 3 entre 18 más un 8º ok entonces
aquí redoblan los tambores y le picamos
enter nos queda 56.50 35 56.5 sale de
jamis y minimizar esto entonces x es
aproximadamente igual a 56.5 x es
aproximadamente igual a 56.5 y entonces
con esto ya sabemos dónde hacer el corte
regresamos aquí arriba cortamos
aproximadamente el 56.5 y con eso vamos
a obtener el área combinada mínima